and I've got to make my decision
Samir I saw a chance to fulfill my baby
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh snap we did it
let's go what's up everybody I am Persia
I am here with Jacob and we're gonna
play some smash and we're gonna check
out the new character Joker fresh off
the presses and first of all I'm just
super excited to be here it's my first
reading with GameSpot live so hello and
I can't wait to play games with you guys
all the time moving forward so it's
gonna be really exciting and later on
we're gonna have some matches gonna have
an open Lobby so make sure you join our
game and let's play some smash but I
think we should hop into the action
alright well we'll play some Joker at
first maybe a little bit we can try out
his moves check out the new stage
especially and then after that we'll
switch over and open up an arena so you
guys can beat me at Super Smash Bros
that is an open challenge okay that was
officially the challenge of the day so
you can I don't really know if we have
the right stage face okay cool
that is the right stage so yes um Joker
just came out from persona 5
I haven't played too much of the persona
games I did play the fighting game the
persona fight was actually really fun I
was a Yukiko mean when I was playing
nuts but this is cool smash has
introduced so many awesome characters to
this game yeah this one in particular
was such a surprise like I knew they
were gonna try to do some crazy things
but for some reason I just never thought
it would be Joker
I'm not complaining because I like Joker
and persona 5 quite a bit and he looks
pretty slick he has some cool mechanics
he does have that rebellion gauge that
helps him activate his persona which
makes him even stronger yep kind of like
a double trigger esque type thing he
does kind of remind me a lot of
Bayonetta
too with all of his gunplay
yeah he's got a knife and a gun they
pointed out in the hype video for this
but yeah and he actually is a pretty
small character looking at him in you
know side-by-side some of these other
characters especially dangan yeah I have
it set so there's final smash gauges
just so we can check out some of the
final smashes because his final smash in
particular is really cool even though I
normally don't play with final smashes
okay gotta enjoy all of the game and all
of its glorious and exacts oh I didn't
make that so for everybody
tuning in at home and watching please
feel free to ask us questions what do
you want to see from this character he
is brand spanking new so if you want to
see anything specific we can have Jacob
test it out for you speaking of which
how many people were actually able to
download this update cuz it took me
forever
I heard the queue was pretty box Knight
says the stage looks pretty good I agree
I think it's pretty cool and I think if
the music changes or something like that
the colors of the stage change so if you
pick up persona 5 song music track it's
gonna be it's gonna have this color it's
gonna be this color if you pick a four
it'll it'll have a yellow yellow color
to it and then three it'll have a blue
so Joker actually has a pretty cool kit
he has some counters he has you know his
gun and his sword his projectiles from
his guns do different things and he also
has what his side B does damage over
time it kind of make it burns you that
which is pretty cool I played a little
bit of Phong and show you a brighter
side so I kind of like poison character
with that poison effects
yeah and it's even better when you have
our sin out with you
unfortunately our
so yeah crime I am doing great
thanks for asking you asked tell us
about what you do will we see you
regularly on the stream yes you will
I'm actually a commentator and a host
i've commentated a lot of you know
fighting in tournaments and some FPS
tournaments as well I also have hosted a
bunch of different events and it all led
me here it's a game spot so it's pretty
exciting and I'm really looking forward
to playing a lot of games on the stream
and playing with you guys and you know I
play a lot of different games but you
know smash has always been like this
spectator game for me like I can
appreciate the craft but you know it's
tough that's every other fighting game
spectator game except for Smash Bros is
the only one I've managed to pick up I
think since I started playing fighting
games which is maybe like 10 years ago
and it's always been like Capcom
fighters and 2d fighters and games like
that I just started playing Tekken last
few months so that's my first 3d fighter
but the biggest thing I think for me in
Smash that I think is really you know
takes a lot of skill is like tilts like
moves where you barely have like tilt
the stick and do the move for it to come
on like that isn't that takes some
control David they made it a little bit
easier in this one there's like certain
buttons you can hit that shortcut that
so you don't really need to do those
light tilts like for instance the I
forgot what that move was called but the
short hop attack was like kind of a pain
to do before but now if you just hit
jump and attack at the same time you'll
do a short hop oh nice which makes it
more accessible because as much as I do
love smash I never got that in India
think of it but now that there's this I
can like you know actually like be doing
some of these short hops then yeah
that's pretty cool because a lot of
fighting games in general they do have
that execution barriers somewhere yeah
you know it's not that I think it's a
bad thing that they have it I think it's
cool that's what's that's you know the
level of players apart from each other
but yeah that was just something I
struggled was so hard cuz even playing
regular fighting games
I manhandle my arcade stick like I you
added weight to my arcade stick so I
could be heavier by how much I manhandle
why are hasting so the idea of like how
do you do the tilt stuff like very
astonishing to me but you know everyone
I know that has played smash for a long
time they're like that's not even hard
probably like the least thing you'd have
to worry about learning this game at a
competitive level and I'm like but yes
sorry we went on a tangent there I am
now looking at your questions
crime is a regular you'll probably I
don't know I just got hit by that you'll
probably see his name in chat a lot he's
always here well welcome back
nice to meet you I don't like final
smashes that's pretty insane
but they're all cool all the noise so
fancy hardly Pacific do much damage
didn't kill him all right and then I
gotta get out of here like a you know
Pope character probably less focus on
damage more focus on you know doing that
that annoying keep away shipping him to
death yeah he's got the guns which
you're pretty good and his guns I think
they're more effective at a closer range
yeah we've got our sin - they're really
good
[Music]
I believe Eric will still be around
don't worry you guys but we're kind of
helping you know lighten the load and
bringing in more people to play more
games so I'm pretty sure you guys still
be seeing you around all right so the
characters been out for like what
twenty-four hours maybe at the most not
even think technically came out around
6:00 Pacific last night but most people
can't download like I don't think I was
actually finally able downloaded like
10:00 or 11:00 so I played a little bit
of them last night late at night and
then I try to play a little bit this
morning but I had to you know do that
thing called work although now I get to
play more pretty interesting so far as
like a a Dante esque style makes it like
a Bayonetta esque style
we'll just call a little bit of chic in
there too Oh a little bit of a medley of
pretty cool characters if you ask me and
then just bringing that persona to the
mix also I know it's a nice little
change up people are saying he's pretty
Opie but I don't I don't know maybe it's
just cause he's so early and haven't
played him a ton but he seems pretty
pretty balanced but obviously that
conversation can change very quickly
right it's early people are still you
know figuring out the character figure
out different strategies from what I've
seen so far just you know within this
first day is he has a lot of setups into
edge guards which are good his up air is
pretty good and we'll finish Mario with
my finisher if I can do it got him with
the turnaround you can do it twice like
you go one way zoom in so you can go
back to the early way and I think it
goes straight to game if he dies so if
if that would have killed him it would
have gone straight to the finish screen
like the windscreen
but it didn't kill him which is kind of
a bummer because he had almost 60 damage
on him and didn't kill him but he did
that testing out some Joker gameplay
right now he has a brand new character
Jacob here man in the station's later on
we're gonna open up in a lobby so please
join us play some games during the lobby
we may or may not be playing Joker but
definitely join up we want to play some
depends how good people are if I'm
getting my ass kicked and I don't know
I'll probably switch to one of my better
characters fair enough fair enough yeah
for those of you who were lucky enough
to get your download going what do you
think of the character so far do you
think that they did him justice um sorry
was that some ear chat what do you think
justice from what you've seen so far
yeah I think so I it's still pretty
early I gotta play a more but I really
like his moveset I like I wish there was
more I could do with his up standard up
be his grappling hook because I feel
like there could be some really cool
things with that but it seems like since
it only goes one direction it you can't
like I don't know you could probably do
some really neat things otherwise if I
could like grab on to someone and pull
them toward me but yeah his hook does
look pretty cool if someone's on a
platform above him you can yank them
through the platform bring them down to
you as well which is which is cool so he
has a little bit of a key play a SPECT
but then he also has tools to close the
gap and bring you closer and stuff like
that and of course you can also use that
hook to get back onto the platform you
know to snag the stage does have pretty
good range pretty good range so so far
so good
looks like some of you in the chat I've
been impressed so far Smasher Josh says
Joker's awesome I'm very impressed with
him
kyoool the two Thomas Kate Lu a it says
brilliant
I don't know if that was in regards to
Joker but I'm gonna go ahead probably my
playing I'm curious if you'll think of a
stage though cuz the I like this look at
the stage but I could see it getting
annoying because these walls show up
you'll be like about to finish someone
in the wall will show up and they'll
survive longer and also it seems pretty
big like I feel like you have to really
hit them hard to get them out of here
which is interesting it's something that
was more common in old smash games but I
feel like they more or less got rid of
that oh I'm gonna stay over here Huff is
angry alright missed out on that what
else can we tell you guys about Joker
right now
I did take I did take some notes that's
what I like to do I'd like to take some
notes um and most of these notes are
probably a little bit more towards you
know his setups and stuff and like his
tools and not so much maybe the
character himself so how much do you
know about Joker the character um I mean
I played through all of persona 5 so a
good amount but it's been a while since
I played it to use and I came to Matt
come out two and a half years a year and
a half I don't know but yeah Joker is
the player character and some five
and I've seen all of his tons
they're so cute yes yeah they're not
gonna let me do more of them but oh
there we go there we go yes three
different ones I think and they're all
adorable they're all and they're their
arsenal do something to when he's at me
time as well which is kind of cool
although they're not gonna let me do any
tongs
it seems yeah you guys were just you
know practicing getting a little bit
practice in against the computers right
now before we begin to open up some
lobbies but he's definitely pretty cool
he looks really fancy he looks like he's
gonna be annoying once he gets a little
bit more fleshed out as a character
because even with his gunshots like in
the air and stuff like that you can move
around while you're shooting so that's
like good evasion tactics you can also
like shoo and then move again and shoot
while you're in the air so he does have
a lot of youth in taxes whoops which are
cool I'm kind of looking forward to
seeing how people implement that into
the game plan yeah it'll be interesting
to see really high level play with them
if he even makes it he probably will but
you know there's always this character
especially in smash a game with this
huge of a roster where it's like there's
a lot of characters that just kind of
get neglected in that high level play
Thomas chimed in the Chinese said yes
that was torched okay thank you for the
clarification
Fox my asks if I'm Persian I am NOT but
I actually get that question a lot and I
get people who will like message me like
pictures of Persian you know writing and
ask me if I can translate and stuff like
that and I always feel so bad so my gosh
I could help you out but I can't I am
NOT Persian I'm actually half Japanese
half Mexican
them a little bit of a mix but yeah a
lot of people do you ask me that so it's
a question there it is there it yes
should we start opening it up yeah we
can do that game so the rules that I
usually set is I do one stock 1v1 no
items no final smash normally you'd
probably play with more but just because
typically there's we get a full Lobby
pretty quickly that one just keeps
people moving through all right so you
heard the man those are the rules on the
table we're gonna do some 1v1 action
some some one-and-done action pretty
much because once dark right
so please join up for people watching
how can they find us
I'm gonna create the arena and an add a
password
[Music]
what's the secret code
[Music]
I have a rule set I think already set
for this chrono Capri says this game is
hard to be honest hey I'm right there
with you dude and like I watch all the
time and I have a lot of friends who are
really good this game and they always
act like pick it up but I don't know it
it's definitely different than any other
game I've ever played then maybe like a
platformer room but there's no pressure
on that type of game you know you're not
fighting against people like in this
game so I'm totally on board with you
there yeah yeah so please join up we got
the secret code we'll let you guys know
the secret code it's 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 as
if you guys would ever be able to get
back code don't forget if you do forget
let me know I'll repeat it back to you
the super secret don't share it I think
they'll also need the ID which I can
pull up they need ID and you need the
password there it is so the idea is and
MV wov
1 2 3 4 I don't know who's on the
GameSpot chap actually I guess I can
enter it right now oh yeah it's MV wov
ok and then the password is 1 2 3 4
there we go
so one in Dunn's let's put your pride on
the line real quick dude our lobby we
gave you all the specifics to do so and
we'll see you know and if I lose that
means we're gonna be watching them play
because I'm gonna get kicked out and
thrown in the back of the line yep the
queue will start again and there you're
going with Joker you did mention earlier
that if you get your ass kicked you're
gonna switch but you set up a 1v1 so you
kind of set yourself up for failure here
but it's okay
it's fine oh you got VOP up against Jake
right now he's an actor
do some work because all of our viewers
are out for blood right now oh it's not
looking good no oh no you're fine he's
got you've got a gun and a knife ray and
I bleed exactly
and arson and Morgana
Manny swinging that mallets oof okay
okay shooting here this little spike on
the edge Oh No this might be it for me
okay
you're on stage if this was a final
destination I think I'd be done those
grabs you're still alive all right yes
the lobby is full already that sounds
about right
okay we got some time we're doing well I
mean that's how the cookie crumbles
sometimes guys that's what happens when
you'd play one and done
yep that's okay we get to watch you guys
in action now Jake's gonna go to the
back of the line it's gonna contemplate
that loss think about it think about it
simmer let it simmer
but yes good job the Opie GG oh they
even there's a joker icon down to nice
and we've got Tim up next he's gonna
show off some Joker okay he's here to
maybe show you some notes on the Joker
match up here we'll see this King baby
seems pretty good right he's got the
solid blaze got the fundamentals on lock
ooh
Thanks slow and steady
I mean Opie has life Lee doesn't do too
much looks like Tim maybe just figuring
out Joker as well okay all right it's
it's closer than IJ so far exactly the
pace is slow nice edge right there from
the Opie throws again then consistent
with these stones hello Lionel
I am Persia nice to meet you I am a new
host yesterday was my first day but
today is my first gamespot livestream
and I'm here with Jacob hello Jacob is a
plan some smash however yeah in life I
was playing some smash now I'm in line
to play some smash we got zo key on a 2
game win streak already so so far so
good I'm gonna do one more is Joker so
I'll go through the line through one
mores Joker if it doesn't go well and
I'm gonna switch well it looks like VOP
has gone through the joker gauntlet
I know because now we have relaxed up to
bat also with the Joker we're kind of
seeing a little bit from everyone I kind
of like that everyone is willing to try
out this new character - yeah I know
right that's a high stakes one and done
situation no no I don't feel bad for
being out because at least they can
still see Joker play exactly you guys
are helping us not be liars title here
for Joker gameplay and the music is very
good and this time we have Joker with
the life Lee looks like he's going for a
heavy like keep away game when there's
running away yeah just dinging them
oh nice okay relax is a adapting to the
throw game plan from the okie right now
arson is out oh just like that we had
such hope oh yeah he had a good first
half that's the thing with King DD is
like he hits you a couple times and
that's it yeah alright if you got hit my
mine real I think yeah alright Josh is
up next let's see if we're gonna get
another Joker game oh we also got crime
in here what's it the battle is about to
starts
yes Co P is on a three game win streak
let's see if Josh can dethrone him he is
whipping out the Joker gameplay as well
I respect it you see you see the Opie
was like I'm going a hundred percent
from the start and going with my mane
everybody else they're willing to try
out Joker who is the opium man and the
twitch chat he probably can't respond
right now because he is that POV of the
ope
okay alright so we see you in game and
in chat thank you all again for joining
us
o counter oh that was scary he's got a
crazy recovery he goes so high oh man
josh is still alive yeah DDT is just
fighting an army of jokers game keeper
says I'm noticing people aren't using
rebellious spirit much that's a great
way to bring our scene arson out quickly
yes he does have the rebellion gauge and
the guard so like the guard if you
charge it and you absorb hits it kind of
builds up your page similar to maybe I
guess focus attack and stuff like that
absorbing hits while you're doing that
can give you the that meter so yeah a
great way to build up the gauge
otherwise you build it up by getting
beat up so yeah definitely a better
alternative the gauge you do still take
damage but it's reduced damage and it
builds the edge so so finally no Joker
yeah getting a wolf and King Dedede
still the opie yes he is on a streak
right now
tour through all of our jokers let's see
if deer a can in the street the Opie has
been pretty solid
oh just gonna have a snack it's brunch
after all who jumps out rainy playing
passive everyone's been going for the
passive route against the ope right now
because I think up close he's just been
too fundamentally sound oh wow it was
just like a few hits here and there no
heavy combos nothing crazy maybe a throw
but yeah it was just solid hit after
solid hit it's quick VOP making quick
work of these one and Den's this is
probably like a dream let's go up next
we got the homie crime stepping up
alright alright crime you got to do it
you got it in the streak great box oh
thanks for showing us a new DLC King
Dedede I get it I get it you guys hey we
did have four Joker's try to take the
GOP alright crime you got this but now
we have the kerbs
yes oh my gosh
no wonder the OPA is so fat he's just
eating everyone up
hey throws again so consistent with
those throws Oh
he's his setups are pretty good to it
that with that spiked ball yeah it's
just slow and steady wins the race
crime is trying right into that
easy-peasy Bo Peep so he's done a full
lap yeah he's beating everyone in the
lobby now okay you know what I know we
want to show Joker gameplay but I think
we need to in the streak and then go
back to Joker so the problem is if I
switch characters I'll get kicked out of
the queue so I'm gonna do one more joke
and then I'll switch all right no
pressure but this is all on you know all
right everyone you need this then Jake
your power right now oh he left he was
like two free we played it out and then
was like I'm done all right
well you know thanks for coming by
though Opie great great gameplay we
enjoyed watching now more Joker action
for everyone else who wanted to see that
and also Thank You Opie you could have
definitely stayed and and played all day
but being courteous to the other viewers
much appreciated much respect and you
know hopefully you stay tuned and and
watch the rest of the stream Dragon Ball
fanboy sighs you should have kicked them
out we didn't need to because he was
respectful enough to play his matches
and then head out whoa
I looked away for like one second to
talk to you guys and Jake destroyed his
opponent in the Joker mirror I should
probably have changed his color just
because everyone's gonna be the standard
color and it's gonna
a little tough to see it well ultimately
names are yeah good game good game
yes gg gg we've got a point on the board
for Jake let's go got one these one and
guns are serious more Joker mirrors this
is what I like to see we did say we had
Joker gameplay after all all right Tim
let's see how this goes
all right good we're playing the new
stage Sheikh vs Tim he picked the other
colour the alternate costume I mean he's
wearing his school uniform Jake looks
like yeah take just like that
unfortunately Tim fell off the stage it
happens and that's why I like one life
is so unforgiving
because you make one wrong mistake and
then that's it there's no there's no
second shot but you know he does have
that grappling hook to grab the edge so
maybe next time Tim when you're in that
situation use the grapple hook at least
to try it even if you feel like you're
too far away you know it's better than
just falling to your death Chile says
hello hello welcome to the stream and hi
everyone else in the stream as well we
hope you've been enjoying our place so
far we've been checking out Joker
getting some matches in we do have an
open Lobby if you'd like to join and
play what was the idea was and earlier
in the chat maybe when I get when I get
kicked again I can pull that up we can
look at it it is pretty full right now
though yes so if you want to try and
join last we checked it was full but the
ID is M v wo V and the passwords one two
three four if you'd like to join I know
we did have someone step out of the
queue
so there might be maybe one spot open
maybe not we'll see we'll see but
definitely stay tuned we'll be here
playing with you guys for a while so
plenty of time to get some matches in
that was close I thought I was done now
now you gotta have confidence got a
steak clutch it's not over till it's
over Jake if there's anything I've
learned playing fighting games never
over till you Lisa's after seeing Joker
reveal and smash I died and then Jesus
resurrected me the office when Joker got
announced the entire office was just
everyone was screaming so out of nowhere
all right cool some Joker burgesses wolf
action Jake is on a winch to charge my
controller tomorrow I brought a cord in
here for that in case that happens I
don't know ray is just trying to you
know get this over with Wilfred
controller died maybe I'll let him win
this one so I can charge my control all
the OS you're still in this we got
artisan we're buff now ooh nice okay
nice and you're gonna get that damage
over time with that side B ooh see that
damn daubers I'm Jeff but you in the
life lead oh this is cool this is cool
nice avoiding the gunshot but ouch that
hurt
oh I thought I rolled out of that
all right good game charger yes
Joker's definitely is like a really
small looking character chrono copper
says Joker so thin and Caden Lee says Jo
Christman but a bit light so yeah he's
very he's a small Swift nimble little
character all right good good job DeRay
now it's now the lobby is yours good
luck yes good luck you've ended the
streak now Jake is a spectator we have
some wolf versus bowel we're gonna have
to miss this one so we switch characters
and I'm gonna bring up the ID the arena
ID gray fox says no smash fights between
you two I mean we could I'm horrible but
I'm definitely down play if you guys
want to see that yeah we could do
something however you can play like
teens online cuz then maybe we can play
against people maybe I think so actually
we can try that okay we got all day you
guys are gonna try some stuff so it's
all good right now we're doing these one
and these brutal one and dones yep
I thought when and ends were brutal and
marbled through you know this this is
pretty this is pretty crazy yeah they
want you to play
hey I'll try I was right next round
don't change character yeah like some
Joker
well Laysan I mean I agreed this smash
at all so I don't think it matters like
who I play so we'll stick to the to the
truth and that is you're showing Joker
gameplay today Oh actually you're gonna
have to drag my thing down into the
queue oh it may not let you right now
Oh
oh wait there we go oops
I actually can be good alright well I'm
gonna give it a go next round so let the
downloads begin I'm about to download
you guys will see it hey you never know
this might be like you know sometimes
you just pick up a game you never play
before and then you're just like a
natural this is my VI game you can do it
we got this we got this thank you guys
for having so much faith in us though
that's very nice after this we should be
able to continue spectating so we can
see how these next couple battles go but
it looks like DeRay is still kind of
cleaning house but we got a boy crime
I think last I saw he was using some
Kirby mm-hmm we just pretend like we're
seeing the match happen yeah wolf got
the throw that's as much as I do like
this game the way the arena is set up
like could be a little bit better like
the fact that if you miss the start of
the battle you don't get to spectate the
fact that if you switch characters you
get kicked out of the line like I
understand like if you're winning
if you switch characters that should
probably kick you out but like just
waiting I feel like I should switch
characters change stages you know but we
hope you guys at home have been enjoying
the stream so far we'll probably have
this Lobby open for a while we might
switch to me try some TV to stuff with
you guys but mostly we're just checking
out Joker playing some smash Oh crime
loss No
it's okay okay all right
now we get to spectate for real this
time okay DeRay is still going DeRay
versus Samuel us maybe I should have if
he's still there if this player is still
there then I'll switch to Lucena and see
if I can take them so some raw reaction
this time we've already seen a bit of D
raised wolf today so far but we have a
new opponent entering the ring with some
Roy smoke this pack a flash but nice
throw from deer a again run it back a
little bit of lag ooh that these Wi-Fi
warriors
who's playing on Wi-Fi uh-huh you'd
better tell me right now having some
issue Oh
but so far we aren't Wi-Fi though still
running train right now
[Applause]
would win I can't raise a gentleman no
he's still clapping for his opponent
even though he lost that's a respectable
respect Oh didn't realize we had to
press buttons it's alright Raiden derp
is up next against da we have a spot oh
oh no we don't have a spotter but
someone's changing characters
where's Joker though I know people
people live oh here's a joker right here
good things this is one in tiny because
yeah we don't have a joker matchup it's
only one round Oh No okay don't scare me
like that readin but like we mentioned
earlier that grappling hook is a good
use to get back onto the platforms
obviously you sit there and you saw the
range - he looked pretty far away but
he's still got nice and safely back on
to the platforms but o-m-g DeRay is not
giving Raven any chances right now okay
nice using those downward guns very good
but gets the throw d-ring with a massive
life lead I just roll out of the way big
whiff goes unpunished oh oh woah-oh
could be dangerous Raiden goes for a
double jump to avoid makes it back down
to the platform safely nice guard oh my
gosh the evasion the evasion is real
oh one more hit orange is nice using
those guns coming down to protect
himself but any hit you're right already
said Oh use of the range there he blocks
Justin's I'm putting up a good fight
still definitely playing defensively
guys Gary does not want to eat any hits
right now nice oh oh that side beef went
the wrong way but he didn't get punished
for it and he is still fighting the good
fight
okay Raiden Oh Annie's gonna get that
damage over time hey that was nice
though he kept it alive for a really
long time but Dee Ray's still on a
rampage oh yeah all right up next we got
real axe and DeRay with the wolf but
honestly you know readin that was pretty
good mm-hmm I think if Raiden was
playing like they did and in the first
half how they did in the second half I
think that would have been yeah cause he
lost a lot of lifers yeah and then he
cleaned it up and played really well at
the end it was just he didn't have
enough leeway at that point so pretty
unforgiving these one and done but more
jokes are on the screen relax holdin it
down keeping us true to our word I think
next is you two oh I really will be more
Joker let's see if you're fighting Joker
or more wolf
oh nice using that rebellion Gage and
now our good
my vision here oh and it's very close
very even right now be rare protecting
the edge but relax definitely trying to
keep his space trying to own that real
estate real quick and dear a dang dear a
[Applause]
alright alright ready okay
oh no okay Tim is next got another round
good study do you Rea a little bit more
alright Tim pulls it out for the win
alright chat now's your time how to
learn smash in 30 seconds go oh yeah
we're gonna have fun don't worry it
looks like people though are switching
to their manes now they're like alright
yeah like enough of this dear I made
this serious you can't comes in here to
own it everyone else is playing Joker
maybe the array will be a gentleman also
and leave if he makes it around the
rotation so we can get some more clothes
into the lobby okay see more aggressive
play from the array must be the matchup
gives him a little bit more leniency to
play this way possibly but Tim Oh Tim is
trying but DRA is on point right now oh
let's thing about Ganondorf she's need a
couple big hits yeah ooh nice stayed on
the ledge let him whip that charged up
the tag didn't want to deal with it oh
wow oh dear eyes out see Tim did it Tim
did a he ended the streak it wasn't
looking good there for a second but you
kept it together good work good work
alright now it is you know it's my turn
alright are you ready for this stellar
choker play that we've been advertising
all day oh wait I gotta press anything
okay should be good it is just loading
figuring things out noise alright here
we go
gray fox says persia this is an Evo
you're right you're right I'm ready okay
I don't think he's gonna let you have
any space - there you go hey that was
pretty good for your first time 17
person damage I think I sweated about 17
percent why do you like water in that
17% as well it's okay you know that
actually only this made me want to play
more as I know do you have a switch no I
well you know I wanted to play Yoshi I
was saying I think I was something I
think you were Erickson earlier but I
wanted to play Yoshi because I used to
watch also play and be like this is the
coolest thing ever
you know Yoshi's Island it's probably
one of my most favorite games of all
times I love Yoshi and it's like I want
to play his character and everyone's
like don't be fooled by watching arm so
play Yoshi it's not that easy he makes
that character look so good not like me
but still yo she's so awesome
at least it's like proven that the
character can be godlike so you know
there's hope in that my the only reason
well I mean I'm not nearly as good as
that obviously but my problem with Yoshi
is that his role is too slow for me
because I roll probably too much I think
it's a detriment how much I roll and his
role is very slow and then if you use
roll too much it just gets slower and
slower so yeah I know she's oh she's
tough for me but he's a lot of fun also
there are two open spots in a lobby
anyone wants to hop in some open spots
thank you crime and thank you to those
who came and played with us GG's hope
you enjoyed the one and duns these
brutal brutal one and guns
I mean they had to make okay a little
context gray foxes Yoshi's Island was
excellent aside from every crying baby
Mario I mean that's what made me and
never want to lose him I was like okay
I'm here I got you you know so that yes
it was annoying it you know at times but
it made me make sure I never dropped him
like it's okay Oh a little bit of lag I
hope this isn't on there and I was just
spectating in Tim say he's gonna go eat
thanks for joining us in GG's yeah thank
you for stopping by watching you play
yes blue bubble box finally joined yay
we're so glad you made it into the lobby
you know there's only a few spots open
or a few available spots pray lobby so
oh ho
we'll see how it plays next game but I
think I think paradise might be kind of
laggy cuz we played with Sam Alice
already and it was fine we haven't
played with well he's out anyway so good
match though good match the chat says
Joker loses every time I won like four
or five in a row with Joker and then
lost my first one we got Raiden coming
up next he was using joke earlier and
doing really well with him also so I'm
excited to see a little bit more mm-hmm
and we slipped one spot left in the
chapter in math the IP is MV wov and the
password is one two three four blue
bubble box is pretty good at Joker maybe
you should take that last spot IP shows
how to play oh he is okay perfect I'm
excited to check it out this question is
for blue bubble box you said you're
pretty good with Joker what do you think
our strong suits right now what do you
like the most about his kit so far as we
watch raid in here he did hits Samuel s
with that side B face meaning I think
that's my favorite move I think it's the
a-ha and especially the powered up one
is very good nice there's a joker win
yep Joker win I see you in the jet
hating on our Joker's we're putting it
work of gear chat alignment we're
learning as we go
Oh back to two spots ooh
two open spots please feel free to join
coming up next is relaxer versus Raiden
Oh
he's backing off now that question you
try to get some answers like and also
I'm not that good that's how I describe
myself like most people I'm I'm pretty
good at smash and then there's those
people who are pretty good at smash and
then I'm just like I can't stand a
chance I mean we've all been there I'm
pretty good yeah
all right we're testing out the taunts
here
mandatory all right and the fighting has
begun mm-hmm
so remember relax versus Raiden and
Raiden's den we've been showing off some
cool stuff so far and we've got Makoto
in the background
what are your favorite Joker costumes
are there more than these two my game
right those are like the styles but then
there's colour swaps I think I just like
a standard one I thought that was so
cool and in the game itself so I
typically just play with it with the
coat and mask and everything but it is
cool you can have his choose an Academy
outfit too
this is very close they both have their
are sent out both around 60 damage
rating derp is at 69 nice it started a
little surely but it looks like they got
more serious hey it's a one and done you
gotta take it seriously great person is
gone for readin a little bit more ice
and left relax but his gun as well back
to the neutral trying to charge up with
that gauge Tim says why does nobody
counter good question
Joker does have a few counters his
counter is weird I haven't quite figured
it out yet
I mean other than the fact that if you
counter at all deflect but like I don't
know that the timing seems kind of weird
how it works I really I do need to
figure that out though ooh nice keeping
the streak alive
you know from a distance those gunshots
that Joker has they don't stop the
cooker from moving in or anything like
that only from a closer distance so you
saw there he was kind of far he was
shooting him and then he kind of just
ran in and punished him pretty cool but
had he been closer that probably
wouldn't have happened so alright I'm
back in it
I'm not playing Joker this time because
I changed characters because I wanted to
BD right but then DRA got beaten right
and then he left
we still have couple spots open for
anybody who would like to join mm-hmm
and face off against the number one
Joker which it honestly I don't know if
there is quite a number one Joker just
yet I know
definitely number one King bien oh yeah
and wealth and oh man so here we go I'm
Jake
going up against a Raiden still sick and
cheer to some joker gameplay although
jake has switched he's taken it
seriously now these one and duns are no
longer gonna be free hmm oh nice
trying to charge them up trying to
charge it up bottom
grab it throw gonna we gonna do
crime says can i play against Persia
it'll be a fair fight
take knows why okay I'm down if our
Lobby aligns us
I can I can pass the controller to you
and crime gets up to yeah you just have
to play as Lucena that's fine it's all
the same but give me a little I'll give
me a couple of days because you know
what I came into this I was excited to
talk about some Joker but now you guys
have me play around now I feel a certain
way and I'm gonna go hit the lab in this
game and come back and I'm gonna win on
one I'm gonna win at least one alright I
got more Joker so you know you can clip
that save it hold it against me until I
win because this guy happen Tim's gonna
come back later he's just eating okay
cool we will see you soon Tim what are
you eating by the way I'm curious I'm a
little hungry myself
[Music]
a more Joker action from Josh this time
Tim says he'll fight you with his Joker
later and he won't suicide you know
we're still learning we're still getting
used to used to Joker it's fine it seems
like Josh knows what he's doing with
Joker
oh no the counter Wow all right there I
go every time the chat is like how come
this doesn't happen like Oh smasher Josh
is excited about that that's going in
his highlight reel ha ha ha good work
that was a good one
up next we got card card
oh crimes back crime is back
we still have one free spot for anyone
interested
SSG goku 6 hello
right back at ya I see a couple of
asking who think the new DLC character
will be I think I think I think there's
a strong case for edrick from I think I
pronounce edrick from dragon a dragon
Dragon Quest just with Dragon Quest 11
coming to switch this summer I could
totally see naive I could see that
happening beyond that though I don't
know I have no idea I heard rumors of
like minecraft Steve I don't know I mean
that game is so popular maybe you know
what character I want to see in this the
T tetromino from patches that would be
pretty good you know they already got so
many random things in here just have the
little block T spin on people I'll be
amazing and then you'll have hard drop
you can jump into the air and hard drive
that would be awesome that would be
pretty good I'd be up for that
cuphead that would be cool rumored cats
at cuphead baby can be cool cuphead
would be cool I actually just really
love that art style I think that's why I
really like skull girls to that art
style is just awesome
cuphead is like you know probably one of
my most favorite I don't even know how
to describe it it's like a platformer
but it's like more exciting than like
most platformers esli and it's just
old-school you know it's not as intense
as like those crazy like shooter like
shoot them up like yeah games like the
playing games are really insane so I
remember when they had all that
controversy and they were like the
person was testing the game they
couldn't get past the tutorial and they
like has this whole controversy about oh
yeah yeah some games are hard for people
you know like I consider myself a pretty
good gamer like touch this and I'm like
woah
[Music]
Betty yeah
all right smasher Josh defeated by Samus
it's okay bro
still in the queue you got your W on
Jake
yep you can still write it right that
moment because as Jake was described to
me by fellow people in the office they
said Oh what is it our resident Smasher
so you know I was like all right I'm
putting all the pressure on you from the
jump so our best though was gash who
left about a week ago but he was like B
he was like I don't know gage and I were
pretty neck-and-neck but he'd always win
like we'd trade blows but he'd always
get that win so I think he had me beat
and max on the video team is also really
good too but he's just very good at
fighting games too in general oh wow I'm
surprised on the range with that Sam is
beating Samuel olace who would have
thought but Sam is on that win streak
now let's go girl
uh yeah grey fox he announced it about a
week a couple weeks ago um if you said
where he is now but I know on Twitter he
talked about it sad day something like
that pretty cool pretty cool we're still
in line but we've got relaxed
stepping up face off business against
the CMAs more in Joker action it's Joker
your favorite character I don't know if
that's directed to you or me I'm gonna
say no oh yeah I just got done gushing
over Yoshi um I don't know who my
favorite is I kind of switched between
Lucena
and zero suit samus cool typically I've
been really liking piranha plant - I
thought prom tonight was a lot of fun I
think they may have nerfed piranha plant
though I didn't check the updates but I
remember people saying piranha plant
being too good which is so hilarious I
know right
I'll act I actually loved that I loved
that something wonky was really cheap
and top-tier I was like that's amazing
Antoine says Batman is my favorite
heroes and Joker and Harley Quinn are my
favorite villains what is your favorite
hero and villain I probably go for hero
daredevil just because that was always
my favorite as a kid and I think I still
like there to have a lot I mean I still
do like daredevil villain
I like Joker - I just think if I Heath
Ledger's Joker in this classic so good
I'm excited for the Joker movie - a lot
of Joker talk for me my favorite hero is
probably Gamora she's pretty badass
favorite villains definitely Albert
Wesker he's a psychopath he is all right
is this beautiful Joe it looks like all
right it looks like it Captain Falcon
helmet though you don't see me fighters
that often there yes it's all it's like
a custom fighter you can import your me
you can like dress it up and then you
can pick from a range of different moves
for each button button like combo so you
can kind of tweak and make your own well
it's kind of like a jump force mm-hmm
I had a lot of fun making my jump forth
character I spent all my money on the
costumes and clothes instead of the
abilities so I had like this vacant
basic kit but I like to kiddin matter
that was a my favorite part of Soul
Calibur was the lace from five was the
character creator and all of the
ridiculous creations people would make I
think it was five it was six most
recently was six
six okay the a character creations call
tekken has a cool a costume generator
thing - oh man this meat fighter is
serious poopins
okay relax still in the lead just about
anything could do it at this point it's
true
curry toe sorry I probably pronounced
that wrong says which other games do you
guys play um I just got done playing SEC
hero I was played a lot of that how many
strands of hair did you lose quite a bit
yeah I've been watching people like play
and suffer to that game it's pretty
great
you know I could like this weird
enjoyment I'm watching people get
destroyed yeah okay so if I beat this
crime will be next so I'll hand you the
controller sounds good and you and crime
can go at it if not someone asked if
we're gonna do a Mortal Kombat 11 stream
yep yeah I hope I like to be countered
is that a threat that's a promise
just kidding I've been sitting yet other
games that I play I play a lot of
different FPS games I play a lot of
fighting games more so 2d fighters
Marvel vs. Capcom
skullgirls I like Street Fighter but Sri
fighter 4 is my preference I'm nice you
know I'm not super into 5 but I play it
from time to time
shooter wise like everything man
overwatch halo Call of Duty Rainbow six
Gears of War
what else everything everything I just I
love shooter so super fun I also love
puzzle games
I love Tetris so I would I haven't even
tried such as 99-minute
which is so sighs because I don't
personally own a switch but I just
recently taught myself how to t spin
because I've been watching a lot of
tetris 99 streams I'm like if you're not
T spinning you're not gonna win games Oh
guess you're not playing crime I know
why you cry now we have to wait another
rotation should we close this and try to
switch the game type I don't think we
can do teams and have an open lobby
though we'd have to be teams and play
random people Oh what do you guys think
like can you set it up to our more than
one person we can game we can do for
four we do four at a time if we'd rather
do that what do you guys think well
we'll watch another matter to you you
guys let us know we do we want to open
this up it's like a four player game you
want to keep running this gauntlet let
us know what do you want to try it out
or we can always try some doubles and
you can watch Jake attempt to carry me
against some online play that might be
kind of fun actually too so you guys let
us know we'll let you pick while we
watch some Donkey Kong races crime the
homie crime I'm sorry we didn't get to
play man
you can blame Jake you can take the next
one
yeah wrestling right now I like this I
kind of like that the stages in this
smash just got even more crazy and long
to you like they were getting more
elaborate as the versions are going on
but this one definitely took the cake oh
there you go crying you just get some
private lobby with teams says Tim Joker
is a WWE Champion
he beat Kofi Joker beat Kofi for the
title all snap that was quick
[Music]
I don't know if they're staging I don't
think there's stage hammer hazards crowd
I don't know if you can drop that on
them that's so cool you can go out into
the walkway I know this is also a tough
one to knock people out because I can't
fall right just gotta hit him real hard
I need to pick this stage when I play
next so I can't fall off all right
Raphael says I'm rooting for whoever is
Joker
let's go relax whoo and here we go let's
go you see that energy Raphael you just
sent it made him win you gotta believe
in the energy Joker Cena I like that
this is a it's good that relaxes winning
his Joker because then we can yes
Joker and keep Joker is the highlight
yeah I mean bubble box says relax is
just murdering people now it's true
we've kind of been seeing him get a
little bit better in better yeah
figuring it out Joker mirror now Smasher
Josh he's been in here for a little
while now who's seeing something me
before
do they have link in this game they do
they have multiple links they have young
link they have link and they have to
link
wait Ben says hi there hello welcome to
the street where I'm playing some smash
for checking out some Joker action and
we do have an open Lobby I don't think
we have any more space spaces left but
they've been opening up over time so
stay tuned might be able to jump in yeah
relax I feel like we've seen him
improved just over that starting to
understand a little bit more Wow
and that's doing that damage over time
relax with the life lead any hit for him
can be it but can he back instead of
safe safely yes he can
Josh kinda gave him the free realm to do
so but that double kick he has right
there goes very far yeah it does that
that running kick anti-air action
relax got it again relax put in now work
get a little no more got it right there
I'll hide
I love the the windscreen too with the
running so classic yeah they did well
they did well not to says this is the
first time on this channel and it's so
nice thanks you too I'm gonna subscribe
thank you thank you we appreciate that
and streaming come back yeah we stream
every well Monday through Friday at
11:00 sometimes we stream a little bit
more too if there's a big game but yeah
every day at 11:00 Pacific yeah so be
there it's okay to be square but just be
here anyways um Tim says it's his first
time too well welcome also to you Tim
you actually got some matches in us in
with us as well yeah oh that's fun yay
new people we're all new and I like it
well your nightmare
Jake's been here I'm near although I'm
not on streams that much so you're new
to the stream room thank you know
someone who may see me just because I am
always the one for Smash Bros oh they're
like we know Jake's gonna be Thursday
right so relax versus Samuel us again
with the Roy I'm not sure if relaxes in
the chat I haven't seen him say anything
yeah I haven't either
but if you are gray foxes purchase the
new games by DLC character yes I love
that I am the new DLC I'm a part of
these the fighters pass all right and
relax still running the gauntlet I like
it relax are you in the chat at all yes
relax if you're in the chat let us know
I'll small fry okay fry what's up
welcome thank you for showing off some
Joker play it's been pretty awesome and
you've been getting better and better
every round so that's been fun to watch
to going up against link I think we did
have someone in the chat asked if the
link was in this game
man you guys are awesome because
everytime the chat requests something
wants to see you something you guys
deliver I mean that's pretty cool so now
we have link in the game going up
against Joker relax we've been doing
pretty well if you can hear me relax
from the research I have done his up air
you can combo into it with itself so if
you do get you know good launch I kind
of want to see you go for that combo
just just to see how uh I mean it seems
pretty practical yeah but I kind of
let's see it in action so if you need a
combo to try your labs let me know try
that one out
jokerz quick like with link a lot of
links moves you like do the input and
then there's like a build up right like
it doesn't do it right away
with Joker its if there's like no no lag
between you and putting the attack it
feels dashing around that's okay see
right there the idea I think he was
trying to go for it back I love that
actually I'm a big fan of like
characters and fighting in set half
counters there are specific countries
you know mm-hmm like high-low projectile
because then you actually do have to
make those reads not exactly was that it
make Fang knocked him out you defeated
our Joker
yes he's officially our Joker now that
I've adopted him he is our Joker now
that was a good run relax it was it was
now you can coming up next we got we got
car car one two three four and then make
things so link link in action and then
after those blue pins you're on deck
poopins then you and then me and then
maybe me versus crying and then if we
get to that point we'll think about the
the next thing we're gonna do yes
probably open it up maybe or someone put
some suggestions for team battles in
here I think it was like make a lobby a
and then we invite people I don't know
that might get kind of complicated yeah
then I oh there goes that might get kind
of messy that was fast
good work
alright poopins she's gonna use that me
fighter again
all right let's see I'm kind of like to
see more of the me fighter
his face is all blurred out to you so
funny it's like every nightmare I've
ever had
oh it's a good different me fight or two
or they put some more clothes on them
some armor on them master of infinity
says how much longer is this open this
will be open for at least another 15
minutes or so oh we might head over to
some team battles soon I'm gonna try to
face off against crime at least once and
then if it doesn't work out then we'll
try some team battles for the end of the
stream house all right see if I can get
the team battles yeah kiss looks like
our chat really wants to see some team
battles Tim says please do team battles
after this round get not this one
specifically we're like two rounds away
from potentially having me versus crime
so I just need Jake to get us there you
just have to win this he doesn't win
this match or goes to battle so crime
you can blame Jake if we don't get to
plate today
crossed hopefully it's okay
antwuan says what anime shows do you
like it's actually so funny you mention
this because yesterday was my first day
they introduced me to everyone and you
know we have a bunch of anime fans in
the office and they were asking the same
questions and you know my favorite anime
right now is Kuroko's basketball because
I love that enemy so much and I love
basketball so it's kind of like great
all around and then they were like oh we
thought you're gonna say like my hair
academia and then I was like well I do
love that stuff
I'm also very generic oh I'm done
I'm sorry what I can do is I can kick I
can kick everyone and then just have you
to do it and then we can then we'll do
team battles alright fair enough
all right we're gonna pretty much close
out this lobby me and crime are gonna
face off and then we're gonna switch to
some team battles for the end of the
stream so that Jake can carry me and we
can all kind of play some team action
we'll see I'm gonna try I feel like last
time I tried to do team battles in an
arena didn't work but we'll see yeah if
it takes too long like we have to
manually invite people it's probably not
gonna be feasible but you know maybe
we'll play online we'll play a couple of
team matches online and maybe if we all
search at the same time we might find
each other I don't know no crime left ah
crime you left oh well he quit it's fine
let's try this team battle thing bit
alright got about if I can get out of
here 15 13 to 15 minutes left so plenty
of time to get some team battles in the
internet is struggling there was there's
a bit more luck there's been a bit more
lag and I can't you know what I have a
lot of people joining and leaving and
staying in a rotation so the lobby is
probably imploding that's fine anime
does rock and swine I agree
alright I might just have to quit close
the game right start all over so let's
see if we can figure those team battles
outs
the internet broke yes are you guys I
mean technology these days it only works
when it wants to
it really does you could test the whole
stream set up everything be a hundred
percent then the moment you click go
live something doesn't work apart
the microphones not working no game
audio it happens me so often however I
set up here it's pretty nice I'm
definitely gonna go home to my set up
and be like what is this potato javion
alright so let's see a team battle eye
candy team battle okay nice and we'll do
we'll change it to like to stock yeah I
need all the stocks I can get oh we can
do this one this is just three lives
we'll do that okay aha see this Lobby is
more advanced than we thought you guys
right so we're gonna play some team
battles yep I'll try my best
call it game spot again and the password
is one two three four I know it's tough
but I believe in you guys once before
what is the first enemy we've ever seen
Pokemon probably you know that's true
but does that count I don't like that
was like you not o or no no sorry I
don't mean like that I'm just friend
you're not in it I press Start hold on
I'm gonna back out we'll figure this out
I think you have to go too quick yeah
you have to do quick play in order to
get someone else in so we can do we can
do teams against CPUs we can do teams
against randoms on the internet but we I
don't think we both can make one well
let's just play some random playing all
right do this see how we do I need two
guys help me a pic oh you know how to
speak Joker this we promised some Joker
play we can do we do Joker team I'll be
the school uniform Joker okay see how
that goes all right the tale of two
jokers fingers crossed
let's see Anna says please give me a
shout out shout outs to Anna thanks for
tuning in hope to see you next time on
GameSpot leg-oh Knapp OS computer okay I
was like alright so this okay oh no I
had no time to no time to learn my moves
we've got three Joker's and a Jigglypuff
that sounds like a sitcom
oh I'm Jake - oh wait I don't think I'm
actually where am i oh did I just fall
off oh I did oh no I lost track of
myself okay we've got more lives
how do I do this down guns I don't know
oh I found it okay hmm okay let me out
of here oh I got arson I got the homie
Oh
oh no I don't think I want to do this
hmm oh yeah I get more guns now because
I have artisan oh you did it the wrong
way okay okay hold up we're getting we
didn't worked I'm doing Oh No
you're all alone you can take one of my
lives if you a and B at the same time
okay I get up
[Music]
okay nice okay I'm learning oh that's
not what I was sleep yeah you are still
yeah okay okay oh no I fell asleep I'm
done that's it for me now I survived
somehow oh my gosh oh there I go sorry
gosh let you down oh yes oh I'm learning
smashed day y'all fell right into that
was okay you know what we getting
somewhere I'm just still figuring out
the moves here I figured out how you use
the hook so your girl ain't falling off
the ledge all day now we won't we're not
gonna be match them all right
[Music]
yes jaqen Evo person oh wait
Jacob prayers at you go doubles we
contribute we get this uh we did arena
for quite a while to him I think we're
the stream probably won't last much
longer so we're just gonna do a couple
more rounds of this and call it but
definitely like whenever there's a new
character or something new and smash we
like to stream it so make sure subscribe
come by and we'll keep doing those
arenas and sometimes if there's a slow
day tweet stream smash through and just
set up arenas and so you can we have
done that in a while but it's definitely
something I like to do where am I oh I'm
here oh there's stage hazards the ice is
slippery I'm staying off the ice
[Music]
Oh No Oh No
[Music]
oh shoot oh shoot how about you get away
what Wow
No okay that's hard all right all right
okay that's throw
[Music]
oh my gosh I'm stuck
I'm trying okay how do I do these fun
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I don't like the stage so slippy oh
snap I matched my heart out right there
and I think I did some damage out but
Donkey Kong's being revenge on moon No
all right cut it out Oh
[Music]
oh man this mr. Game & Watch has not
lost the light I know I'm in the water I
guess Joker can't swim I don't know [ __ ]
that's a bad stage I don't know why
people pick stages like that well I got
three not good enough though Hey oh you
know what
I gave 82 prison damage I hold that
that's something at least it wasn't like
one person only Oddie exposed it's so
funny
all right I think we have time for like
one more game I might pick a different
character for this latter day let's see
all sticky joking
now how we bushi yeah two jokers and in
that first match is three Joker's I
definitely thought I was one of the
other Joker's at one point and I was
like okay um oh oh you know what I'm
definitely Yoshi mean let's go we stream
every weekday at 11 a.m. for those
wondering and those tuning in for the
first time so please please come and
hang out with us and we'd love to play
more games with you guys and all that
good stuff
Oh Nora gets trapped in between this I I
don't know oh that's you
[Music]
Oh counter you gotta watch out for that
one
nice hit him there we go yo got one
got another nice let's go tried to
counter but I was a little too late no
no I'm just a Yoshi no okay okay
I like how I move my own body as if like
the more I raise myself my character is
gonna be alive it's okay
we're doing well
[Music]
oh shoot Oh No
so much concentration oh no I had that
and then I landed on that move all right
all right
GG's you know what that was close and
I'm 100% Yoshi man
starting right now but yeah that was our
last match which was super fun and we're
gonna wrap up the stream now but I
personally just want to say thank you to
everyone for tuning in and being so
awesome this is my first stream with
GameSpot live so that's really exciting
and you can definitely see more of me
I'm prese this is Jake and you guys we
had an awesome time playing some Joker
playing this matches with you guys and
also throwing down on that doubles I
think next time we should definitely set
aside more time for more practice and
I'll be better at smash to hopefully
I'll be better to have a new motivation
but yes thank you guys so much for
tuning in please tune in every single
weekday at 11 a.m. Pacific time right
here and subscribe so can't wait to see
you guys next time and you're awesome so
just stay that way and we'll see you
guys later
[Music]